[Music]
the most important thing to know if you
only know one things that disaster
robots make the disaster go away faster
[Music]
my name is Robin Murphy I'm a professor
of computer science and engineering at
Texas A&M and I work with disaster
robots 1995 the Oklahoma City bombing
happened one of my grad students went up
and helped and he came back and said
we've got to do it differently we could
have had robots like her being designed
to go to Mars to get into places where
people and dogs can't go
when we're talking about our robots
either ground aerial or Marine robots
that can help responders do things that
they can't do any other way and so in
1995 we all started working toward
disaster robots it was 2001 before we
actually used one that was the first use
of ground robots for disaster it's the
ability to do things you couldn't do any
other way they needed to get more than
18 feet into the rubble robots can go
into these places to get to where there
might have been survivors if I can see
what I need to see I can make good
decisions to keep the responders safe so
this is the part where we make fun of me
for driving so notice that right now I'm
driving heads up but really the trick of
a robot is to get out get beyond visual
line of sight because that's really the
point disaster City is one of the
Emergency Management complexes that
Texas A&M has it's designed to test into
train search-and-rescue teams on how to
conduct search and rescue missions
we've supplied robots for 28 disasters
earthquakes hurricane Harvey we assisted
with the Fukushima Daiichi nuclear
accident when we go we bring robots and
people that we've tested and practiced
within our training exercises when the
biggest challenges to doing work in
rescue robotics is not the robotics it's
the everything else you're going to a
different world it's really challenging
to be at a disaster there's a
physiological and psychological impact
of that it really takes quite at all so
you have to be really good at what
you're doing but my job is so incredibly
fulfilling it's about the science and
the technology and the way it could be
used for societal good that's a big deal
to me
[Music]